souvenez vous
ces quelques milliers de réfugiés
originaires du proche orient au fait
trembler les chancelleries occidentales
ils avaient été acheminés aux frontières
de l'europe à la biélorussie
derrière cette opération de
déstabilisation
la main de moossou
tu sais que la question de l'immigration
en europe est incandescente
[Musique]
tous les pays ont eu peur
fondamentalement que si on prenait ces
quelques milliers de réfugiés afghans ou
autre d'un seul coup un million de
nouveaux réfugiés se mettre en route ils
viennent en fait submerger les
frontières européennes
mais l'europe n'a pas cédé
[Applaudissements]
c'était une vraie sont retournés chez
eux
il rêvait
de reproduire l'épisode historique
unique
de l'été 2015
sept ans plus tôt la chancelière angela
merkel ouvre les frontières de
l'allemagne à près de deux millions de
migrants
du jamais vu dans l'histoire européenne
mais la conséquence est immédiate
un parti anti immigrés et populiste
raciste s'impose avec ses manières
brutales sur la scène politique
[Musique]
l'afd
une alternative pour l'allemagne
et câline je peux vous dire que les
sangles en tournée entière les billets
pour la mecque des coûts à tous les
autres joueurs avaient rechuté nom de
présenter le collen d'éveil sur l'état
de notre système social a dit cela et
gouvernés par des bio pédiatre
life des brise les bonnes manières de la
politique allemande
[Musique]
nous pouvons aussi tiré sur les migrants
je n'ai pas tout un problème
ou même les gaz et christiane ut porte
parole de la nd et
les déclarations et nous enchaînent
et se transforment parfois
en actes de violence
mass domi
des services secrets
place l'afd sous surveillance
les menaces que ce parti
et désormais peser
la démocratie
spitz et starlette est clair pour moi
que la vie ne devrait pas qu'un
problème sur le long terme sont john
hayes d'après nos sentiments ce problème
présentant des dangers les plus of mana
à une chute dramatique pour notre
démarche et a travaillé notamment
democraty
life des risques désormais la
dissolution et l'interdiction
des élus se retrouvent avec un statut
équivalent à celui des fichiers s
français
le tabou de l'extrême droite en
allemagne a définitivement sauter commet
l'impensable at il fini par arriver
[Musique]
en 2015 la syrie l'irak l'afghanistan
sont en guerre
e
des millions de civils sont contraints à
l'exil
[Musique]
choisissent l'europe
mais la plupart des pays sont réticents
les accueillir souverain
l'allemagne
vous avez en 2015 ce qu'on appelle une
véritable rupture seillière en 2015
madame merkel décide qu'elle va ouvrir
au fait les frontières et laisser entrer
ces gens et sa formule de l'époque sera
leur chasse naissent nous y arrivons
avec la politique migratoire mangala
merkel pas rentrer dans l'histoire
mais en 2015 personne ne prête attention
critique de la journée
un obscur parti créé par des
intellectuels deux ans plus tôt à
l'origine eurosceptique et nationaliste
donc le parent qui va pendant un an et
demi en fait et gt qui se présente aux
élections et remporte 2 à 3% des voix il
ya véritablement pas d'écho dans la
population tout simplement parce que ce
sont des professeurs d'université qui
parlent comme des professeurs
d'université qui communiquent très mal
[Musique]
la chancelière est au sommet des
sondages
la population accueille des migrants
comme des moutons
[Applaudissements]
je dirais que les applaudissements
étaient destinés à josé paul j
endroit où tout ce qu'ils avaient subi
j'avais de la sympathie pour les jeunes
gens souvent été l'objet de nombreuses
critiques car à mes yeux c'était des
objecteurs de croissance
et ce qui était tout à fait surprenant
c'est qu'il y avait un large consensus
au sein de la population
même si ces personnes étaient
accueillies avec des drapeaux il y avait
cette rupture de l'accueil quelque chose
que nous n'avions jamais connu
auparavant
cette culture d'accueil a duré quelques
mois et puis c'est terminé cette fameuse
nuit là
cette nuit là
c'est celle du 31 décembre 2015
c'est glory
cauchemar
à hambourg
et partout ailleurs en allemagne des
jeunes femmes s'apprêtent à fêter le
nouvel an
dans une totale insouciance
à la télévision quelques heures plus tôt
guélat merkel présente ses voeux ils
sont évidemment
consacrée aux migrants
limite pour grenoble
le soir de la saint sylvestre
il ya un mois et demi arabesques exact
j'ai dit compte des conséquences de
cette crise et de ses guerres secrètes
du raed fattouh fils au goût de migrants
comme il n'y en a jamais vu depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale
fields and push déplaçait beaucoup et
échapper à la mort sf fâche taille il
est normal que nous aidions ceux qui
viennent se réfugier chez nous et bounce
souffle au retour mais ce soir là des
délinquants qui n'ont rien à voir avec
la vague de migrants
peut aussi faire la fête
j'avais cru calage à leur façon
l'épicentre du séisme se situe à cologne
entre l'église et la garde
ces jeunes jeunes créent très vite en
quarts
[Musique]
nous faudra yoka l entrée de la gaze la
belge dépense d'environ 600 personnes
c'était surtout des hommes la plupart
était originaire
il était de tuer ma maman
entre comme
en boîte en zinc en
graphie on a attrapé les faits ce niveau
là on cultive également verser
l'intérieur de la cuisse on utilise un
ordi on a même touché à la brosse pomper
seulement d'offrir à nos pas vraiment
trippeux de la pch
ses agresseurs sont très mobiles
et se déplacent temps de vous
autour de la gare
[Musique]
rien je me rend dingue mais à un moment
on a tiré très fort sur l'alcool entre
malaga il est tombé sous les jo c'est là
qu'il est décrit en animant déchiré et
je me suis retrouvé en sous-vêtements
face à l'église mais le froid note la
côte 11 curling
parce que chez nous la ceinture de leur
dire en ce qu'elle faisait une crise de
peigne à dents à préserver
on avait essayé de lui enlever sur lui
tribaux et l'alcool
à cologne
la police identifie plusieurs voyons les
petits dealers qu'elle connaît déjà
la crète et sont souvent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà au début on a remarqué que j'étais
blessé mais j'avais un grand plus à
l'intérieur de la cuisse et un autre sur
le braque les plans
[Musique]
jessica ignore qu'elle n'est pas la
seule dans cette situation
le même scénario s'est reproduit dans
d'autres villes
la rumeur de ces agressions se propage
vite et remonte aux journalistes qui
sont de permanence ce soir là
que des signalements des événements fils
dire que les dégâts sur les réseaux des
premiers médias de masse avait publié un
rapport en janvier il disait souvent ces
paisibles allossery tous d'aller bien le
scout
de hambourg à cologne la police ne
signale aucun problème grave
mais ce 1er janvier vers midi une jeune
femme contacte alors une journaliste du
connacht tageszeitung
elle affirme avoir été violée dans la
nuit
avec oleg la collègue décidé
alors que la police n'avait rien
confirmé
nous avons été le premier média en
allemagne a réveillé ce qui s'était
passé reste que paris
disait emea dont des centaines
jamais autant de viol n'avait été commis
en si peu de temps
l'enquêté révélera que les agresseurs
s'étaient donné rendez vous via les
réseaux sociaux
un guet-apens
qui semblait préméditée
comme en témoigne la découverte
deux morceaux de patxi
le kit du parfait prédateurs
traduit de l'arabe vers l'allemand
cossa
je veux viser
je vais te tuer
face au scandale le chef de la police de
cologne démissionne
m
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
publiera un rapport de plus de 1000
pages sur les événements de cette soirée
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui ont volé
quelques zones une grande vide allemand
tel scénario peut-il se dérouler pendant
que sans qu'il n'y ait eu aucune
intervention appropriée
en février 2016 la côte dans gala merkel
s'effondre elle passe de 75 %
à 40% d'opinions favorables
il ya toujours aujourd'hui les
accusations selon lesquelles les médias
n'ont pas informé correctement le plein
de points ne mentionnant pas l'origine
des auteurs de ces actes
auraient été nous ne vous dirons pas que
c'était les étrangers
source au sein de la police nous ont
déclaré
il ya une directive
ni vu le compas l'information qui
concerne les agresseurs rires ah parce
que c'est politiquement délicat
ce silence
produit l'effet inverse que celui
recherché
c'est désormais la totalité des réfugiés
et des migrants qui se retrouve victime
d'un amalgame ou voulu très
maladroitement éviter la presse et les
autorités ne pas dire les choses c'est
ne pas vouloir les traités du reste
france on dire bah oui c'est formidable
le débat politique en allemagne a éludé
la question de l'immigration mais en
réalité ne pas s'en emparer alors qu'il
y a des problèmes extrêmement important
qui nous sont posées et bien c'est
laisser
le pire prendre en charge ce sujet
meistratzheim 10 on peut dire que c'est
beaucoup en allemagne
cette nuit marque à lui truc pêche
profonde autorités traquent orchidées
par la guerre et cela également en
allemagne de façon très
impressionniste de droite
ces agressions de la saint sylvestre
vont servir de rampe de lancement à
l'afd
qui s'engouffrait dans la brèche
le parti va recentrer tout sans
programme sur le rejet de l'immigration
il décolle dans les sondages lors des
dernières élections septembre 2021
l'immigration et la sécurité restait des
thèmes centraux de la campagne
[Applaudissements]
il ya eu 1 500 migrants qui sont arrivés
à l'allemagne
par exemple les syriens y en a eu huit
cent mille civils syriens seuls 80% soit
en âge de travailler
préfère s'atteler aux aides sociales il
en est la règle d'or
ces chiffres ne correspondent pas à la
réalité mais peu importe le public y
croit
nous abordent des thèmes que les autres
partants ils n'abordent pas
ces partis ont tendance à balayer tous
les problèmes
qu'on n'aborde pas les questions
sept ans plus tard des agressions de la
nuit de la saint-sylvestre reste
toujours ancré dans les mémoires
je n'ai que j'ai
18 ans je suis un second rôle pour
jeûner l'alerté depuis trois ans et l'an
dernier j'ai rejoint le paris
les anciens partis politiques ont
l'effet secret dénommé the spécialement
dans le vé de l'est du pays
ce sont des endroits dans lequel les
femmes ne peuvent pas sortir seul dans
la rade car elles ont peur de style
à croire cette militante l'allemagne
c'est orange mécanique
alors que ce pays est l'un des plus sûrs
et d'europe
michael clos 9 qui ancien journaliste un
polémiste parfois comparé à eric zemmour
fut l'un des premiers à critiquer la
politique de merkel avant de rejoindre
la
ftc la plus grande décision politique
qui va bouleverser l'équilibré
démographique de l'allemagne comme
jamais depuis 1945
on ne parle d'immigration des
territoires entiers sont aujourd'hui
occupés par des étrangers je trouve cela
absolument scandaleux et ce ne sont pas
des migrants qui veulent s'adapter à la
culture occidentale ils veulent garder
leurs propres mains deuxième fraude fiom
avec en moyenne 20 milliards par an
investi depuis 2015
l'allemagne a réussi à intégrer
l'écrasante majorité de ces migrants
un succès indiscutable
comment s'y est elle prise
pour le savoir
direction en bout
[Musique]
franck auto un milliardaire engagé à
gauche est un supporters de la politique
migratoire de merkel
il est aussi le patron de la chaîne de
télé locale
[Musique]
important de réfugiés alors que n'ont
pas les capacités d'accueil suffisantes
il était évident que la ville allait
être confronté à d'énormes problèmes
premier objectif des autorités
préserver la dignité des migrants en
leur offrant un logement
et c'est dans ces boîtes
des containers
qu'hambourg a trouvé la solution
hambourg est le premier port d'allemagne
face à l'afflux de migrants des sociétés
qui exploitent ces milliers de
containers se sont mobilisés
[Musique]
on avait déjà utilisé ces containers
dans le passé au bruit loger des gens
alors quand les migrants sont arrivés
beaucoup de containers ont été
transformés en logements d'urgence
en allemagne aucun migrant ne dort dans
la rue
ici la ville a installé un camp
d'accueil un vrai village avec des
containers transformé en appartements de
deux niveaux
wifi en accès libre
il y a des dizaines de camps comme celui
ci dans toute la région et pas plus de
300 habitants par caen
a joué sur l'air de
kamil on est kurdes d'origine syrienne
il est arrivé à hambourg en 2017 avec sa
famille
il était depuis un an et demi quand nous
l'avions rencontrée
ou d'origine l'est plus aujourd'hui en
syrie non pourquoi rôle non
serré dans mes enfants sont
[Musique]
ils sont habitués à l'allemagne et
ils vont devenir allemand
mes enfants devaient retourner en syrie
ce serait trop difficile pause dans ses
cheveux
kamil et sa famille vivaient à l'être
il appartenait à la petite bourgeoisie
locale
sa femme était enseignante et lui
commerçants il a refusé de rejoindre
l'armée de bachar el assad
je vais mais je ne veux jamais me battre
il est en droit c'est un droit à un
régime par les deux camps à chacun zé
maria une légende
rien de mal lumière at il dit les aides
qu'ils ne veulent pas de bachar le cam
il a dû quitter précipitamment la syrie
pour échapper à la prison
voilà ici on allume la lumière ici il ya
de lille une table avec une chaise des
rideaux tout était là on n'a rien
apporté de syrie mais les francophonies
chaque container de 60 m² est équipé
d'une cuisine aménagée
lorsque l'on sait mettra à travailler on
devra payer nous même le loyer on voit
des rayons
le gouvernement allemand bay jusqu'à ce
qu'on trouve un emploi
je n'ai pas trop le temps dans les
journées et je vais chaque jour compte
des cours d'allemand ensuite je cuisine
pour mes affaires
des comptages avec les habitants
mais pas trop et
c'est un chance pour nous de démarrer
aujourd'hui
leur fils est invité à l'anniversaire
d'un camarade de classe
allô bonjour
je la mènerai je la mène maintenant
mais il me donne à chenôve année
ok
c'est l'anniversaire du petit bourg
c'est mon ami
la mère dont la mère
danoise elle a commencé les seuls à
4' et allégée des genres tarif
le plus bas soit d'autre je parle ni en
allemand ou en arabe arabi l'album la
rade les oublier pourquoi du logar où il
ya beaucoup de noms j'ai tout simplement
arrêter d'apprendre
en transit vers sa nouvelle vie
cette famille fait tout pour s'intégrer
et la clé d'intégration c'est la langue
[Musique]
pour rester en allemagne camille doit
suivre des cours intensifs d'allemand
ils sont obligatoires
vous arrivez à suivre
oui je comprends presque tous
un cursus d'une centaine d'heures au
terme duquel les élèves sont censés
obtenir un niveau suffisant pour trouver
un emploi ou suivre une formation
professeur
[Rires]
moi qui travaille
auprès d'eux parce que tu perds je vais
le je vais je vais faire l'apprentissage
on sera l'air travaillant sur la lande
retour au camp
aux côtés des familles
de nombreux hommes seuls qui ont fui la
guerre
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce qu'éclate conflit en ukraine
hambourg a accueilli plus de 50 mille
réfugiés originaires du proche-orient et
d'afrique
la ville
recevaient 400 demandeurs d'asile par
mois
bonjour foot ensemble avec épouse et
enfants
pour vous ces réfugiés ne veulent pas
tous restés en
doudoune je viens d'un pianiste en
afghane afghanistan il ya
maintenant vous êtes ici depuis deux ans
et vous parlez un peu pas trop
tu sais mon pays n'est pas très sûr des
charrettes tu vois ce que je veux dire
oui ces touristes chinois au tournerions
série gérer agger
moi je viens de syrie au sommet
et vous mondial gr k way vous doivent
rien à faire oui je voudrais mais je ne
peux pas pour le moment
cet irakien à 21 ans il vient d'arriver
à peine revenu de son périple en
méditerranée
rambo anne des
monts jura c'est une ado n'est pas ça on
voit bien les choses
moi aussi j'ai pris le bateau club mon
but c'est ce côté combien doit il ya des
profs et ça coûte 8 9 secondes à
arcandor
ses hommes isolés sans famille jeunes
sont au coeur de la propagande de l'afd
[Musique]
michael krohn obs qui a développé une
sorte de théorie cousine de celle du
grand remplacement en vogue en france
chan newtouch le feu orange pourrait me
dire si vous observez la piratage en
allemagne peut-être huit millions de
personnes en âge de
la majorité de ses affidés migrent ici
appartiennent
déjà exorbitants et ce n'est pas fini la
société va changer associé à la fin mars
quand même de connaître par l'endroit
des guerriers c'est tout simplement
stupide et même criminel de les avoir
laissés venir
micro meneur
au bout ville de référence pour la
qualité de sa politique d'accueil des
migrants n'est pas réceptive au spectre
de la guerre civile qu'agitent michael
krohn offs qui dans la vie la plus riche
d'allemagne l'afd n'a jamais dépassé les
10% des suffrages
hambourg déjà c'est une des plus grandes
villes d'allemagne et de fait dans les
plus grandes villes allemandes l'afd a
en général dans les centres-villes du
mal à son
credo
elle a attiré l'attention sur elle est
courant que les gens avec des solutions
et des slogans
à l'aise mais hambourg ça n'a pas marché
au four nous sommes en ville nous avons
une très longue tradition d'accueil
c'est une ville de l'ouest c'est un port
les ports en général en ml comme
ailleurs c'est plutôt des villes libéral
plutôt des villes qui
échangent beaucoup historiquement qui
ont connu des flux migratoires
mais hambourg n'est pas tout la main
[Musique]
la carte du vote de l'afd révèle un pays
à deux vitesses
à l'ouest
l'afd tourne autour de 10 % des voix
mais à l'est sur les anciens territoires
de l'ex rda communiste elle dépasse les
25%
comment expliquer ce décalage
il faut remonter à l'effondrement du mur
de berlin
et la réunification de la haye
et de l'air
[Musique]
le véritable problème c'est que
l'allemagne n'est pas encore réellement
réunifiée vous avait en fait deux mondes
vous avez d'un côté l'ouest est une
société dans lequel la migration a
toujours eu lieu et vous avez l'est et
alors l'est c'est un monde très à part
parce que c'est une société
désorientation de crise économique la
population sans mal pour des tas de
raisons d'abord parce que le chômage est
important les jeunes s'en vont
des barres d'immeubles de 18 étages
abandonné
[Musique]
des usines désaffectées
dans certains endroits en saxe où
entourage notamment
les ruines de l'ex rda sont encore
intactes elle continue à hanter la
population
[Musique]
et encore un certain nombre de vestiges
de l'allemagne de l'est et des traces
qui font très vivace en souvenir de
beaucoup d'allemands de l'est mais en
fait elles sont là dans les têtes et
politiquement c'est très malin ça a été
très malin de la part de l'afd de le
sentir et d'être capable de le
transformer en offre politique
le paradoxe c'est que l'afd réalise ses
meilleurs scores à l'est alors que ces
territoires n'ont accueilli que très peu
de migrants
vous avez une population qui se sent mal
à l'aise et qui est d'un seul coup
voient arriver 900 mille migrants
auquel on promet des appartements on
promet un soutien financier alors qu'eux
mêmes ont le sentiment d'avoir été
grugés et l'afd a su créer un récit un
récit identitaire
de ce qu'est la nation allemande faire
nation en allemagne ça veut dire aussi
se protéger contre des personnes qui
vont être peut-être d'une autre religion
dominante qui vont venir d'autres
espaces culturels et donc des espaces
nationaux et c'est ici à l'est que la
branche la plus radicale de l'afd s'est
développée
elle est aujourd'hui quasiment
majoritaire au sein du parti avec à sa
tête un ancien prof d'histoire bien
heureux que
je vois des vieux et des jeunes
des hommes et des femmes
en communauté je vois pas qui veut voir
devenir
[Applaudissements]
journaux locaux bouscule le ps a su sur
l'histoire de l'allemagne
il a dénoncé la présence du mémorial de
la shoah au coeur de la capitale berlin
nous les allemands
comme le sauveur du monde
les médias
au coeur de sa capitale
j'en veux que je joue avec les symboles
nazis pourtant interdit par la loi
c'est lui qui a fait glisser le parti à
l'extrême droite
et même le grand patron pourtant un
ancien cadre de la cd ou de parti de
merkel
alexander groland y va lui aussi de ses
provocations
il y a
le nazisme n'aura été qu'une chute
oiseaux dans l'histoire de l'allemagne
alexander cas hollande dirigeants de la
vie
en 2016
l'afd va consolider son emprise
servi par une actualité dramatique
dans la foulée des attentats qui
frappent la france
une dizaine d' attaques sont commises en
allemagne au nom de l'islam radical par
des migrants
des attentats qui marquent l'opinion
comme cette salafistes qui a planté un
couteau dans le cou d'un policier elle
n'a que 15 ans
[Musique]
ou encore cet afghan
qui a attaqué les passagers d'un train
avec une hachette au nom de l'état
islamique
l'essentiel du discours de l'afd à cette
époque est fondamentalement sécuritaire
qui consiste à dire nous avons affaire à
une menace fondamentale contre notre
pays et nous sommes les seuls qui en
fait veulent protéger ce pays
un an après les agressions de la saint
sylvestre sur le marché de noël de
berlin
un camion bélier va défoncer les
barrières de cycle
bilan douze morts
56 blessés
cet attentat s'est du flou brut pour
l'afd
ce tunisien en situation irrégulière
étaient en attente d'extradition
il ya un manque de volonté politique
pour expulser des personnes qui ne
devraient pas être isolés qui sont des
délinquants
maintenant très élevé mais si vous
l'avez mentionné pouvait le faire
l'allemagne a fait le choix de ce climat
la planète c'est une tâche plus
ambitieux que l'instruction des migrants
guérinel non elles sont donc ce n'est
qu'une question de volonté de chine
ces attentats permettent à l'afd de
jouer sur l' amalgame
migrants et gad islam
islam égale terrorisme
bienheureux que le leader de la branche
radicale est l'invité régulier du pays
dida
l'organisation extrémiste raciste anti
islam sous étroite surveillance des
autorités
[Applaudissements]
on a besoin de la liberté de se
rassembler on vous chers amis écrit
l'histoire la foule scande le guen très
sain la presse ment elle est accusée de
cacher la vérité sur l'islam en
allemagne ce slogan n'est pas anodin il
a été inventé par les nazis
[Applaudissements]
l'islam n'est pas vraiment compatible
mais comme société ouverte et
démocratique
oui les musulmans considèrent leur foi
comme une affaire privée sont bien sûr
compatible avec la société occidentale
stanley
nous sommes pour la liberté de religion
et musulmans civils sans soutien sur
sentiers l'allemagne jamais l'islam ne
fait pas partie de l'allemagne et l'eau
ne se mélangeront jamais
l'analyse de l'islam qui est fait c'est
que fondamentalement l'islam par nature
n'est pas une religion donc il considère
que l'islam par nature est impérialiste
et que naturellement il faut que la
nation allemande se déforme
pour la première fois depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale
l'afd a parti d'extrême droite rentrer
au parlement avec 12% de rire
c'est un séisme sans précédent
jason parrott l'entrée de la vidéo
bundestag en 2017 c'est vraiment un
symbole je pense que c'est ça qui a été
le plus choquant pour les allemands
c'est la fulgurance de ce parti et donc
pas fulgurances a fait dire aux annonces
comme quoi on n'était pas immunisé
contre un parti d'extrême droite une
centaine de députés
quant aux le groupe parlementaire
rihanna tu l'a jamais
vu de l'ouest
il faut séparer les députés élus à
l'ouest et le député élu à l'est si vous
prenez les députés élus à l'ouest vous
avez des policiers vous savez dit juge
vous a fait un grand nombre de gens qui
en fait dispose de très haut niveau de
formation qui sont des universitaires
les pratiques changent et avait rappelé
ali
parmi ces élus de l'ouest la redoutable
alice weiden mais que fait cette femme
ou saint-aulaye libre qu'elle appartient
à cette élite mondialisée que le parti
de tellement
elle a mené sa carrière dans la banque
d'affaires goldman sachs
depuis longtemps
déjà
snb madame grès voix pour les personnes
non qualifiées mais en fait vous
réveillera les retraites à l'avenir je
tapais comprendre ce sera bon et reus
yeux le député de gauche où ces engrais
qui valent de l'or vous n'y pensez pas
sérieusement
alice weiden
elle vit en couple avec une srilankaise
matt de peau mais elle ne bronche pas
quand les élus de son parti s'en
prennent à d'autres députés homosexuels
messieurs les députés enfermez vous donc
le week-end prochain dans votre chambre
à coucher avec votre mari essayait de
faire un enfant
si vous y tenez
je retirerais alors tout ce que j'ai dit
à des sujets
doute bien que craint pas grand chose
face aux excès de la
fdc l'ancien président du parlement
européen
l'éminent martin schulz membre du spd de
gauche qui tire la sonnette d'alarmé
duction pour les politiques coupe
l'accès à une seule cause qui concerne
nos minorités dans le dernier set a
signé traditionnelle du fascisme
[Applaudissements]
là encore
comme nous l'avons encore démontré
aujourd'hui
son déficit des banques ramener je
trouve qu'il est temps pour les quelques
traces de se perdre entre de s'opposer à
ce type de rhétorique violine
a conduit à la démolition des balais à
la violence dans les rues c'est ça les
temps mais bon d'agir il est bien sûr de
crachats s'opposent à ces gens monsieur
le président
sortir son fauteuil
l'afd a du mal à attirer des électeurs
sur de nombreux thèmes
avec la crise du coni mais partait tout
extrêmement tentante et de récupérer le
mouvement tu vas tu les opposants au
musée traîne
lors d'une manifestation en sens
interdit de paraître
au sein de l'aef d un certain nombre de
gens ont pensé qu'il était possible
d'utiliser en fait ce potentiel ce
potentiel de de protestataires qui est à
peu près de 10 à 15% la population
simplement le problème c'est que le
potentiel anti vaccins il est
extrêmement différent c'est à dire qu'il
est composée de gens qui ont avant voter
verts et qui n'aime pas du tout elle a
évité vous avez des intéristes de gauche
de droite vous savez l'extrême gauche
partiellement aussi au sein de ce
mouvement tivat
septembre 2021
c'est en pleine crise sanitaire que se
sont déroulées les dernières élections
parlementaires
[Musique]
jusqu'en 1989 la ville de chemnitz en ex
rda
s'appeler karl marx stadt
m
la ville a connu de violentes
manifestations contre les migrants après
l'assassinât d'un allemand 1 afghans et
un irakien
[Musique]
mikhaïl kroutov ski
il fait campagne
son slogan du populisme pur jus
vous pouvez me faire confiance je ne
suis pas un politicien
[Musique]
au piano
sa femme
une pianiste russe qui a vécu en israël
[Musique]
le polémiste est un électron libre il
veut casser l'image d'un parti raciste
il va briser le registre classique de
l'antisémitisme d'extrême-droite
[Applaudissements]
il faut arrêter avec la théorie du
complot juif
mondialiste est un mot grossier pour
désigner des juifs si je ne vais nommer
des exemples de l'egypte mondialisme je
citerai
[Musique]
hillary clinton al gore entamé leur avis
bill gates george soros ans mark
zuckerberg
angela merkel
christine lagarde
il n'y a pas beaucoup de juifs pas mieux
les mondialistes sur la personne riche
politiquement influents qui s'associe à
des personnes de gauche qui veulent
changer leur tour les 1 gagnent bien
leur vie les autres sont à l'aise dans
ce monde
vive l'allemagne je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
dans la salle
les gardes du corps portent le masque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cela faisait longtemps que j'attendais
discours et je vous aurais pas voir
samedi la façon je sais ce que vous
auriez meilleur que celui là
niquette love qui qui est né en saxe est
un modèle de réussite pour son public
dernier jour de campagne
le candidat de l'afd il sera les
sondages le donnent gagnant
verra son avis
via militants de l'afd qui la gauche
c'est forcément le communisme déploient
une banderole qui rappelle les crimes du
stalinisme
100 millions de morts jamais deux
parce que nous sommes contre la hausse
des combats que la démocratie stop au
nazisme
oui je la connais elle vient d'israël
at il dit qu'il ne peut pas être un nazi
qui ne peut pas être fasciste parce
qu'il est marié à cette femme obscure
mais qu'on nous a tous et le discret de
gao land rights et bien hollande voulait
le
clown hausse à dire constellé de la
liberté d'expression de ce qui est
acceptable et de ce qui peut être
contre les homosexuels
pour ça que nous sommes ici
j'ai beaucoup d'amis en israël ont aussi
nommé partie d'ailleurs nombreuses et
personne ne vous dis pas que
les allemands qui disait ce sont des
rats
je pense que tu es un nazi
ou bien
si vous voulez savoir ce qu'ils en asie
allez donc à buchenwald où je suis
traité nous donner
à chemnitz
une sorte de front républicain
c'est monté contre le candidat claude
offs qui
le soir des résultats il domine avec 34%
des voix mais personne n'applaudit à
part ses hommes
[Musique]
c'est pas mal comme de bas ça peut être
lieu
les candidats de gauche sont écoutés
attendez attendez on n'avait pas encore
gagné
ce sont définitivement de mauvais
résultats
je suis très choquée que l'afd puisse en
avoir
mais il faut at work ce ne sont que les
premiers résultats de la soirée
beaucoup de choses peuvent encore
arriver
on va au qg dans la tente du
dépouillement des autres bureaux de vote
mis quelque 9 ce qui rejoint son équipe
de campagne
les bons tuyaux c'est bien pour
la gauche si la fda gagne plus de voir
mais on va attendre les résultats des
chinois pour l'instant on a les mêmes
résultats qu'en 2017 beaucoup de
bulletins dépouillés
l'as vence de michael clown offs qui sur
son rival de gauche se réduit mais le
candidat et ses supporteurs continuent à
traquer en soirée des militants
d'extrême gauche sont signalés
c'est déjà la
rentrée dans le calme des renforts ont
été déployés
il ya des extrémistes de gauche ils sont
une soixantaine avec du mortier sont
maintenant dans le centre et la
prochaine étape nous attaquer la police
veille à ce que rien ne nous arrive
des antilles faa arrive
on a l'habitude
très souvent
[Rires]
[Musique]
les antifas n'arriveront jamais jusqu'à
la permanence de l'iphone
rien mais l'euphorie du début de la
soirée dépasser
michael que lorsqu'il a été rattrapé par
le candidat de gauche
qui a recueilli nous électorat de la
droite traditionnelle
vers 23 heures c'est terminé il est
définitivement battu [__] consolation
partout ailleurs en allemagne l'afd a
reculé par rapport aux élections de 2017
elle ne fut plus que 10% des voix c'est
à la fois un échec et c'est à la fois un
succès pour la ft pourquoi un échec
parce qu'ils n'ont pas progressé sur le
plan électoral et pourquoi n'ont ils pas
progressé sur le plan électoral parce
que la question de l'immigration ne se
posait plus fondamentalement c'était
plus le la voie ouverte comme c'était en
2017 mais les 10% sont inquiétants parce
que ça prouve que l'électorat fd est
devenu stable c'est à dire que la
théorie des politistes était à l'origine
qu'ils s'agissaient la partie
protestation
or ce parti de protestation a muté en un
parti
stable
[Musique]
le score décevant de l'afd
est aussi dû à ses multiples
provocations racistes
violente
qui effraie la majorité de l'électorat
hier il y avait une fête avec 50
retraités 50 étudiants est dit n'est
gravé
land rover seul membre de l'afd
brûler les maisons des réfugiés n'est
pas un acte d'agression
sandro harcèle membres de l'afd
[Musique]
et c'est au cours d'une nuit d'été 2010
que toute cette rhétorique de haine va
basculer dans la rubrique criminels
fighter lübke un député de la bd où le
parti d'angela merkel fervent soutien de
sa politique migratoire
est abattu à bout portant en pleine tête
par hamilton
un sympathisant du goût
combat 18 le chiffre 18 correspondant
aux initiales d'adolphe hitler
gouvernement et dit la question c'est
toujours la même pendant une grande
responsabilité
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent d'un conférence
de presse
le député avait déclaré que ceux qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec la politique
d'immigration donc à émigrer eux mêmes
c'est une déclaration scandaleuse de la
part d'un policier il aurait dû être
réprimandés mais bon évidemment tout le
monde devrait pouvoir animer son opinion
hillman ce sans avoir à craindre
quelques mois après l'assassinât du
député
un autre terroriste d'extrême droite
abattent de personnes dans la rue après
avoir tenté de forcer la porte d'une
synagogue
no 19 février 2020 neuf personnes sont
assassinées alarmes automatiques dans
des bars à chicha par année on est
l'afd est pointé du doigt
est-ce que la rhétorique de l'aef n'est
responsable des actes de violence là je
vous pose la question qui responsable
des actes de violences commis par les
musulmans qui est responsable des actes
de violences commis par l'extrême gauche
chaque année l'office fédéral de la
police criminelle rapporte que les
migrants comme est beaucoup plus de
crimes contre les allemands que les
allemands n'en commettre entre les
migrants
toutes les analyses que ce sera les
sondages d'opinion ou les où les
analyses des services secrets allemands
montrent qu'il existe une forte
corrélation naturellement entre à la
multiplicité des discours anti
immigration et le passage à la violence
mais encore une fois il faut il faut
être très clair il n'y a pas de membres
de l'afd qui ont été compromis dans ces
attentats
[Musique]
stephan kramer et le responsable des
services secrets de thuringe
en 2021 ils placent sous surveillance
leader de la branche radicale du parti
le mouvement des jeunesses du parti
en raison des menaces qu'il faut peser
sur la démocratie
on va ne sont pas utiles quand
parrainera d'un patin il est écrit dans
le programme d'un parti sns une menace
en allemagne que la religion n'a rien à
faire ici
l'indication
indice est en bien des points qui sont
passés par là sont si fins fiscales et
niches noah offenstadt mais c'est
pourtant de taille le parti des
programmes en compte globale menti zones
arides hoc face au refus face aux
panthers einstein
[Musique]
en mars 2002 c'est la totalité de la nef
des kippas sous la surveillance des
services secrets
une situation unique dans une démocratie
pourra partis représentés au parlement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que de
surveiller la fdc en france
effectivement comme si la dgs y
surveiller les activités des militants
du rassemblement national en gros ça
veut dire ça donc effectivement pour les
observateurs français c'est que c'est
c'est une décision qui peut désarçonner
visite à madagascar ce que je pense de
cette surveillance à la silla n'existe
dans aucun pays
dans aucune démocratie à l'exception
d'allemagne les autorités chargées de
surveiller l'opposition c'était une
ravine bananière c'est de la corruption
afrique c'est l'afrique ce n'est pas
bien du démocratie est au coeur de
l'europe
à terme le parti risque l'interdiction
et la dissolution
la procédure est longue et complexe
avec la guerre en ukraine
[Musique]
l'afd qui bénéficie des faveurs de
vladimir poutine
nage désormais à contre-courant de
l'écrasante majorité
de l'opinion allemande
c'est le seul parti à défendre moscou et
reprendre ses flics news les plus
grossières
[Musique]
venus pour désamorcer la scission du
charme et m'ont
guidé
par l'idéologie qui enfin dont les
laboratoires et ouvre un créneau
la machine et il y encore
face à ces excès ces dérives racistes de
nombreux cadres montrent aujourd'hui
quittait l'afd
en laissant sa branche radicale
s'imposer le parti risque de se placer
définitivement hors la loi mais en
banalisant son discours il risque aussi
de perdre des électeurs l'heure des
choix a définitivement sonné pour l'afd
[Musique]